so
what does the code do
nobody [__] knows
who wrote it
nobody [__] knows what we do know
is that it lies
no famine no Wars come on
just distract its users sends them on
little quests
and for what
[__] wings
oh look Susie's got wings
what wonderful act of kindness you must
have done to be bestowed this great
honor by the Magnificent algorithm oh
[__]
gosh [__]
dog [__]
I see it no it's very literal
good stuff
you know what wings are none uh sort of
it's like a status thing right like a
blue check mark or black AMEX card you
use it long enough it gives you wings
right wrong
it uses you long enough
it gives you strings
step one
convince every user that I need Wings to
be happy to be respected
to be seen step two Nightwing's [__]
impossible to get
there are dummies out there that have
done a thousand Good Deeds gone on every
idiotic Quest it sends them on and
they're no closer to the jackpot so it
offers a shortcut instant wins
one hell of a balloon payment
their life
expiration dates
just deploy at your local pyramid Center
and hope the algorithm gives you a nice
chunk of time before you have to report
back and get [__] incinerated
I know what you're thinking I should
have peed first you're thinking crikey
I'm a non-one the holy [__] does this
have to do with me well two weeks ago
the algorithm picked every user in
Nevada California and New Mexico it ping
them a photo
a photo of you
hey
told you to remove that slide from the
deck man this photo was taken nearly
three years ago the night your daddy
died the Lazarus shroud right
you are way out of bounds JQ
I'm sorry
it's been years since the algorithm did
a wide Blaster located known user it
only does it when some poor drongo is
about to be
she doesn't want chosen one yeah
the Big D Force feeds Heroes journey to
its Network you know you're special
you're the one
expert in world religions a priest who
lost his faith
Antiquities professor
they were recruited
algorithms love cliches
and there's no cliche bigger
than the quest for the Holy Grail
[Music]
most overused MacGuffin ever not to
mention it's [__] pretend
but if the grill is not real why send me
after it because it's testing you you
got chosen one all right just not to
find some dumb [__] cop
it wants you
to be part of its Mod Squad
Somewhere Out There known as a massive
server Farm
but no algorithm with this power in
reach can operate at this level without
people to maintain it
rile quests I would find those people
This Server Farm is the mothership none
if we can find it we can shut it down if
we can't
foreign
just a matter of time before every
[__] person on Earth does whatever it
asks them to
you need my help no
you need air help
play along Mike like you care about the
Grail then
and tells you where its brine is
you tell us
blow it to Kingdom [__] come
it's a lot
yeah it's a lot
except why would it want me on its
maintenance team I don't know anything
about computers that's exactly why
it wants cleaning ladies not architects
you pose no threat right okay well let's
say that we're true instead of super
offensive to me when cleaning ladies
it's not brainwashing us right like we
don't have to do anything we don't want
to because
we still make our own choices
[Music]
yeah
okay we're on our way
[Music]